[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want tim is back
finally your first time today and also
jason for the first time today
welcome back for the first time in
forever
what song is that that's from frozen
that's words
you know what's funny i was i was like
me and bart were eating the other day
after we shot a barbell brigade video
and he's like what have you been
watching lately on like on
burberry video because what have you
been watching lately on like on netflix
and stuff i was like and i was kind of
thinking of shows
and he's like man i've been he's like
i've been watching moana like twice a
week and i'm like
twice a day dude i'm like bro me and
chia put on moana all the time he's like
oh i mean because of taika
i was like oh okay well we just love it
i love it
for that baby that's why it'll work out
because i love
disney movies i love like musicals and
[ __ ] like i think
if our baby wants to put on a disney
movie over and over and over again i'll
be like
[ __ ] yeah is it weird that i really love
moana
a lot too but i try not to watch
the movie that often because i kind of
want to savor it and i don't want to
like ruin it for myself by watching it
too much
no it's not weird it's a little weird
that's how i think it's weird i deprive
myself of things i love
my favorite clothes i wear the least
amount and shoes yeah and so she finds
out really weird about me because she's
like if it's my favorite shirt
i'm going to wear over and over again
but for me i want to preserve it so i
actually wear the clothes that i hate
the most the most
yeah really the same that's weird
honestly that is weird we're both
[ __ ] weird i wear the stuff that i
like
all the time yeah same because i'm like
i bought it because i want to wear it
from the shitty stuff to the best part
at the end
i do the opposite interesting
example if i get a rib eye steak i get
the toughest part which is the round
and then i'll eat the cap at the end
because that shit's the best part
by the time you get to the best part
it's like cold yeah yeah but would you
rather have the cold tough part
or would you rather have the cold
softener and also you're hungrier in the
beginning
so then you can bear the tough part
better but you're hungrier so you would
but it's not tough tough it's just
a little bit i'm with you here's what i
do my guy but i'm going to eat the whole
thing most of it what with the ribeye i
start with the dope part with the fatty
part and then
i'll eat some more middle and i'll come
back i like i'll save a little bit i
kind of
no actually no i eat the i eat the part
that i like first yes
but but the clothes too like it's like
if you have some special clothes and
you're like
this one's special and then you pull it
out for special times
it feels different and then i just
i have my favorite [ __ ] clothes though
my favorite [ __ ] clothes are the ones
that i really like it
but i know that it's not the like my
best
i think for the movie thing though i
don't think it's weird because it's like
um
at least i can kind of relate to it
because there's certain parts of it that
make you feel a type of way or like you
just don't want to wear it out
so i think for me i'm not going to feel
that anymore yeah so like
uh moana is another movie that i like
and i've learned to like it because like
taika loves it so much but i think if i
liked it on my own i wouldn't want to
watch it as much because then i'm not
going to like it anymore it's kind of
like when you have your
favorite song as your alarm at least for
me like if it's playing
every time you wake me up i'm like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate this song now once i
loved it
that's kind of what happened with isaac
when he like especially during the
lockdown stuff he was watching the
office
oh he watched it like five times i think
or six times or something like that back
to back to back to back to back
and i [ __ ] love that show so in the
beginning we were watching it with him a
lot but then it got to the point where
casey and i were getting tired of it and
we're like okay
isaac we love you we love enjoying the
show with you
but just for the sake of us loving this
show as well we can't watch it with you
anymore it's driving it's gonna make me
hate this show so we had to stop
we took a long ass break on the office
you know for movies that i love like
moana
or like um blood sport blood sport
or i was gonna say uh forgetting sarah
marshall which is a movie i can put on
all the time is that the one slapping
the base
no no okay that that one's i love you i
love you man okay um
for kingston marshall to go to hawaii
yeah yeah i got it i mixed it up richard
i can put on movies like i'll put those
on in the background because i've seen
them so many times
and then now it's like it's comforting
almost to hear it and then during the
dope parts i'll pause like my chores
whatever and watch
and then go back to my i know what i
indulge in what
music if i like something i'll listen to
it
non-stop and then i'll have a desire to
listen to it
like as soon as i feel it and hear the
song i have to find that song that i
wanted to feel
and cinnabuns cinnabon i don't indulge
in it as much
but if i want it i'll start at your
least favorite part of that no
i don't i don't i don't i don't have at
least
starting at the end of the version no no
no no no so it builds up
it's all backwards because the course is
the best part so let me uh
yeah rewind it no yeah the only time i
actually did that with the song that i
really liked was
it was just because it was a foreign
song and i was trying to learn the
lyrics and i listened to it
oh i remember that song yeah the flop
flop ippor
empori i can't say was it romanian or
bulgarian yeah something like that
but we it's because we heard it on this
one show um
comrade detectives yeah comrade
detectives and they have this one song
and i [ __ ]
love that song like it hits so hard for
me singing right now
um i had to sing with the song i can't
just give you the lyrics because i can't
pronounce it right
but i did learn the song from the most
part like most of the sounds
i'm like [ __ ] yeah i learned a new
language but not even yeah
but that's the only time i could replay
like repeat listen to it because then
i'll go crazy
like this morning i woke up and the
first thing i was like
i made that song what song was it i
don't know the name
there's no name it's it's a it's
untitled
it's the it's like uh music it's there's
no lyrics
is it jazz no it's like a it's a
homeless man playing a piano
oh that one yeah it's a russian homeless
man
that i just type in homeless piano
and then i don't know the name of the
song or nothing and you didn't save it
well here's the thing is like he
actually someone discovered him after
the streets i like the streets version
some guy just recorded
but then there's another one where they
made an album with them
but it's all written in russian so i
don't know how to type
russian so how am i gonna find it so the
only way is like oh
i woke up i'm like i need to hear that
song so i'm like homeless man piano and
i play it
and i'm listening to it i'm like ah it's
it's good man
it hits really good it's true casey
found some japanese
jazz and the latin one uh
is it yeah i think it was that one all
right but it's in japan it's in kanji so
we can't type it but i have it in my
library it's in soup
what
am i wrong no no i'm just like okay i uh
you're too
educated i have i've been listening to
uh this uh this brazilian dude named sue
george
uh like all the time and it's all like
portuguese but i have no idea what he's
saying but like
it's lit yeah that's me with afrobeats
i'm like
don't know you look for the playlist
yeah it's for vibes
it's the vibes and sometimes i'll be
like i'll be mad like all these [ __ ]
kids they're not even listening to the
lyrics anymore i'm like i guess i don't
really listen lyrics either
just so there's this new artist that i
recently um discovered myself i
discovered
is it
i found this new artist that's true
because he was new to me
hilarious how do you say his name
jamiroquai
but what did i say like jam rockwell
chick she's actually a french american
so she was born in france but then she
was raised in san francisco her name is
lolo lolo zuwai but it's like spelled
like french
you mean lovozawa you mean the loser has
been out for like 30 years
why but dude you guys gotta look her up
she has some dope ass music and she also
it's like it's bilingual it's english
and french oh wow
yeah she kills it that's like stevie
wonder is my sharia more
it's like french for just three words it
backs to english
oh yeah i don't know that [ __ ] you you
didn't i do i know why do you think we
use [ __ ] that we don't even want
like like clothes and things
what do we use oh because you know how
they don't want to wear the nice clothes
so they save it because what i should do
i just thought about it i should throw
away everything
that i don't really care about and like
and just get everything that i think is
dope as [ __ ] duh that's what i recently
did when we moved i totally did the
marine condo
i'm broke yeah i think so i think that's
something to do with the brokenness
yeah because you don't throw [ __ ] away
so you wear it until it
dies on you yeah because i i grew up
broke i don't want to be broke anymore
so i'm like i broke no more throw that
broke [ __ ] away
there's occasions you want to wear like
a there's occasions when you want to
wear like a
old beat up shirt then i'm so rich that
i tell myself i'm going to wear nice
[ __ ]
to be possible sometimes that's more
comfortable then you buy the [ __ ] it's a
little bit more expensive have you seen
what is it called one of those shoes
you're gonna eat and make a mess have
you seen those goose shoes
it's called um i think they're just
goose and they're like eight hundred
dollars and they look like
yeah it's something the ones that looked
at dirty yeah already yeah yes look it
up
yeah something good if you know you're
gonna go and get dirty
oh don't you just want to get dirty
clothes look how much they are
wait which one do i have all of those
all of those look at the prices on that
but look at how they look that's so dumb
that's some rich people [ __ ] that is why
would you pay so much money to get it
gucci that's why
not all of them like these are gucci
these are conversations the point is
with this at least is when you're so
rich you
you're not wearing things long enough
for it to get dirty and have character
the way
i this is my assumption yeah yeah you
don't right you don't wear it long
enough to have that
natural wear and tear that makes it look
cool so they're like let me just
buy it already that's so weird and
they're not even
like they're not even cool looking shoes
they're pretty cool looking
oh they i like them i wouldn't swap me
unless i was like a [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
then i'd probably buy it because i'm
like
i'm [ __ ] rich oh someone googled why
is golden goose so expensive
golden goose sneakers are hand crafted
by a homeless man yeah then they take it
give them back to me [ __ ]
and finish by craftsmanship they have a
bunch of [ __ ] children in developing
countries messing up the playing soccer
with the shoes
for a month and then they get the shoes
back and then they yeah selling them for
a thousand dollars they're expensive
low-key pissing me off why are they so
expensive i'm telling you original
golden goose supreme
collaboration but you know what the
dirty if you
if you're not rich and you spend a lot
of money then you probably got a lot of
debt because today's video is brought to
you
by upstart baby and during these tough
times everyone is looking for a way to
feel more financially secure and if
you're still
throwing money every month at high
interest credit card debt because you'll
be buying stupid ass [ __ ] like this
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that
knows you're more than just a credit
score now is the time to find out how
low your upstart rate can be
to help pay off your high interest
credit card debt from buying all of them
goo shoes
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history
in the form of a smarter rate but you
don't need a degree or diploma to apply
which is awesome
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online so
convenient
they offer loans from one thousand
dollars all the way up to fifty thousand
dollars so you can consolidate your debt
into one
easy fixed-rate payment so it makes
things simple so you can pay off your
debt
upstart makes it fast simple to check
your rate too this is just a soft pull
it won't affect your credit score the
hard part
happens if you accept your rate and
proceed with your application the best
part if the loan is approved and
accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business days
are crazy that's a lot of money like
this look at that oh wow
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals so free yourself from
the burden of high
interest credit card debt to get back to
using your money your way with
upstart okay now see why upstart has a
4.9 out of 5 rating on trustpilot and
hurry
to upstart.com record to find out how
low your upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record your loan amount will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application not all
applicants
will qualify for the full amount very
nice
very nice very nice you know uh spending
frivolously is not a good idea and
um i do think that i just have old
habits that i was
raised with and i just
try to use everything that way and it
just feels weird
i know it's so true because when i try
shopping for stuff like now i'm telling
myself because i learned from you guys
like
you get what you pay for so if you pay
for something really cheap
it's gonna break down on you you're
gonna have to spend more for the most
part yeah for the most part but what if
you get free
dope [ __ ] like i get free dope [ __ ] from
barbell
i get free dope [ __ ] from fear of mom
right here shout outs to asians never
die
i get i did a re uh uh uh i did a race
uh spartan race and i got a free shirt
from reebok
don't wear that to go to sleep you you
wear it see you
use it that's true okay so
it's free yeah and it's dope do you guys
find it wrong is that why
you feel like it's not no no it's just
kind of like why
pay for [ __ ] when you get a lot of free
[ __ ] yeah i'm like if there's nothing
wrong with why you guys do it and you
guys
it doesn't bother not everyone gets free
stuff though right
you're literally talking about like you
know i don't get pretty
i get what you're saying you go up broke
so sometimes it's like uh you you think
like
why do i need to be wasting money on the
dumb [ __ ] but then
some one sometime i think the homie ryan
reminded me and he was like hey bro
you didn't work this hard yes to like
not enjoy it and i was like you [ __ ]
right yes
i i like imma buy these golden goose
shoes
i mean it's a balance right like if all
your if all your like priorities are
right
and all the you have all your bases
covered and then you got some play money
or are you safe to have this play money
then [ __ ] play yeah that's why when
we were buying stuff for the house
i was i was like it was really hard for
me to change my mentality but i was just
like listen
i really like this piece of furniture i
normally would not spend this money
but [ __ ] that it's quality [ __ ] yeah and
it's gonna make my house look nice
so i'm buying it but it was really
difficult for me to go through cars it's
in your house and it looks good right
especially when you use it every day too
there we go it got its money
are they in videos yeah all right they
paid for themselves you can write it off
yeah so so i can do that with like
furniture
and like i guess my car but when it
comes to clothing and stuff i still
haven't passed that
threshold i don't think i have a problem
with buying [ __ ] i have a problem with
throwing away [ __ ]
so if it's still good and it's like
clean
and there's no holes in it i'm like why
should i throw this away
but then why don't you tell yourself
you're gonna put it somewhere where
you're not going to remember and you're
not going to see it for the next four
years
so then because there's always a time
when i'm like throw a shirt away just
because it has a hole
that's true you still could keep it but
i'm still i'm still
i know that's why a lot of my things are
still here because i know there always
is a day when i regret it
i knew i wanted that jacket because it's
gonna [ __ ] look good with this [ __ ]
yeah
then you can just buy it again no you
can't find the same one
you can't but you'll find something
better no
no chia wants me to get rid of so much
of my like my closet [ __ ] cause like
things i haven't worn in like years
like your fubu shirts you like my
avocado food shirts i wish i had money
when fooba was popping oh my god what if
we do a skit
of we need a whole audience of people
wearing
2008 clothes yeah
you have everyone's award yeah but if i
throw it away
exactly no wardrobe help me get rid of
my stuff
is um limited closet space well no i
actually
gained a lot of closet space in the new
place but the the thing that helped me
shed
is because like just like you it's
really hard for me to let go of stuff
because i'm like they're still
usable like i can't just get rid of it
it's so easy
i got i gave it all to my aunt who she
ends up
she has a business where she goes to
like swap meets and stuff and she sells
things so like she's
getting an income out of my stuff so
then like that helped me
let it go that makes sense yeah that was
that's
the only way i was able to let go of
something i gave so much [ __ ] to my
friends
and when i was moving i was like oh yeah
this is i should move all the time
because it's going to make me
let go of [ __ ] yeah i shouldn't have a
big house but then like when you're
getting rid of your clothes
and then you think of like man how
fashion kind of goes in circles
and now i think of like [ __ ] all these
cool ass shirts that i had
that i gave away because i don't wear
big clothes anymore
that were cool and now it's like people
aren't really wearing
tight shirts anymore and now it's like i
would have these dope [ __ ] like
vintage
perfect shirts but my stupid mom and my
stupid wife make me want to give away
all my clothes
women it's not my fault tim not speaking
for you
but i have trouble finding shirts that
fit so when i do find two clothes that
fit
it's it's it's like i gotta get them
tailored or i gotta get you know so it's
like cause you're trying to show off the
guns bro just wear a loose shirt like
everyone else you'll be good
don't wear any clothes like me but
you're wearing clothes right now
because i'm trying to be presentable
wait so you get a
t-shirts tailored like what do you do
like what do you like any kind of pants
any kind of like formal [ __ ] like shirt
shirts or any kind of suits
they all have you can keep forever yeah
yeah we're talking about throwaway
clothes i have a hard time throwing away
hoodies
and like t-shirts i would never throw
away what do i have a hard time throwing
away
all your clothes holy holy underwear
so she she holds on to clothes so like
me and her i think she actually isn't a
she's not a pack rat for sure but i
think i'm so extreme that it makes her
seem like a pack rat
because for me if i don't wear it so if
it's like normal clothes if i don't wear
it for a month i just throw it away i
give them one
let's pass it off you just said that you
you wear your [ __ ] clothes all the time
and then you keep the best clothes
he they're [ __ ] with price tags and then
he ends up just giving away brand new
[ __ ] throw away your dope
[ __ ] i have dope [ __ ] but then i just
your [ __ ] clothes how does that make
sense it doesn't
it doesn't make any sense there's some
shoes he's only worn once and they're
[ __ ] brand new and he's giving them
and it's like give it to like my cousin
or i give it to her can you not match
them
no he can he only eats the the shitty
part of the ribbon
but you take the cap i'm not gonna eat
this just eats the vegetables and gives
away the whole steak
is what the [ __ ] but i don't know why
but when i go in the closet i see it
hanging there with the price tag still
onyx i've never even worn it yet
it makes me feel good and then i'm like
wait time to get rid of this stuff
he has so many get rid of it if it makes
you feel good i don't know i feel like
you know
took his christmas presents and then
just gave it away
yeah he doesn't even get to play with it
oh she did that that's so sad
we heard that a million times though i
remember that what you gotta do
for the other traumatic [ __ ] childhood
but not that one at the very
least take pictures in the new [ __ ] and
then give it away
so then it's good it's worth it just do
it one time yeah
i mean i guess if it's worth it for him
then if it makes him happy
new [ __ ] that i barely wear it's because
i don't have the full outfit so it
doesn't match with anything and i had to
end up giving it away
man i used to not even be like that used
to not be a choice for me i would buy
shoes and then this is back like broke
days working on footlocker and [ __ ] i
would buy a pair of shoes and be like
this sweater would be dope with these
shoes so i would like you to build an
outfit i'd build an outfit like over the
course of like months and months so i'd
buy like a dope jacket put on layaway
for like months and be like by the time
this is like february
i'll have the rest of this outfit
together or if you've worn it so much
and it gets worn out then you start like
changing it or adding
i mean maybe not patches but like adding
different [ __ ] like i was we were broke
[Music]
so